Any time you combine
spirituality and capitalism,
it has the potential to go really dark.
We look at the success,
we look at the failure,
we look at the ambition,
we look at the heartbreak.
-We!
-Work!
Everybody scream!
WeCrashed is our take on the story of
Adam and Rebekah
Neumann.
We meet Adam and Rebekah
when they are
kind of at the beginning
of building a company
about building dreams.
In her mind, it's more than
a shared workspace.
It's a profound idea
about how to connect all of humanity.
And she just knew
that they could change the world.
We're selling an experience...
a community.
Adam's really passionate,
and he was a great salesman,
but he also failed a lot.
They were both struggling
to survive in New York City,
two struggling people
who happened to find gold.
You have to make them see.
See what?
You're a supernova.
They're crazy in love,
so the heights
that they achieved in their life
were absolutely
fueled by their connection,
which also meant that the lows
were fueled by their connection.
They build something remarkable
with billions of dollars in revenue.
You were supposed to be
getting us funding.
But now you're telling us
to spend more?
Miguel, we spend to grow.
And you see how
money and power
starts infecting them.
There's late nights,
there's sleep deprivation,
there's a lot of drinking,
kind of really blurring the lines
between work and personal.
I say, "We!"
You say, "Work!"
-We!
-Work!
It's fascinating that
really smart,
hard-working people
can be swept up
and intoxicated by power.
You think you built this?
I built this!
We've gotten to see
Adam and Rebekah's
public face,
but this... our hope is
you'll truly feel like you're getting
a behind-the-scenes glimpse
of what's played out on the front pages.
I think the thing
that makes WeCrashed unique
is we are living in a moment
where there is this very real push
to be billionaires.
And this show looks at
the potential cost of that.
We made a choice
not to villainize them.
The media's already done that.
And the true story
is so much more complicated,
and it's so much more interesting.
Let's show you who these people are
and let you into their personal journey.
I just can't be nothing again.
You'll never be nothing.
I want you to meet
the legendary Adam Neumann.
To have these Oscar-winning actors
at the center of it,
it's really special.
Annie Hathaway is simply one of the best.
Annie is just perfect.
I've genuinely never had
an experience like this before.
It was an amazing part
to really get to sink my teeth into.
You took everything I believe in!
I think Jared playing Adam,
he's magnetic.
You can't take your eyes off of him.
-Are you with me?
-Yes!
It's an epic rise and fall story
like you've never seen before.
In some way,
this is an aspirational story.
In some ways, it's a cautionary tale.
I love this series.
I really enjoyed that challenge,
to play a bigger-than-life
person like this.
It's, in every way, fun.
And it's exciting,
it's adventurous,
it's hilarious,
and it's very touching.
We're doing something different.
We're building a community.
We do this together,
we can change everything.